did you hear michael barisson say
anything
yes what did you hear him say
i heard him say
uh mostly speaking to rob at that point
um
you know i don't want a war how do i fix
this how how can i make this all better
something
along those lines almost exact words
along those lines how can i make this
better i don't want to war
i just want to fix everything and make
everything good again
what
or how would you describe his demeanor
when he said that
calm
just
yeah i would just like calm
was he yelling
no
did you do anything after hearing him
say that
i
after hearing him say that
i
went down
to go find out
how he wanted to do that i was willing
to listen to this
whereas
robert
when he said this i guess to robert
robert just said listen you know there's
lawyers involved
we can make things better that's fine
just you know have our lawyers talk
and
rob went back up onto the porch
i then
was thinking you know all this stuff had
been happening for the past couple of
days
you know michael i've been calling
police in us for reasons that we didn't
even know why
and
not this that it was out of character
um for him to act one way one day and
then you know be nice the next day
but
i kind of wanted to know so i walked
over to him and said
you know
how do you plan to make this better how
do you you know you have
a bill or something i was
saying something about
the bill that he had to settle with rob
but i didn't get that far
because why not
the minute i started talking pretty much
or
yeah within the minute i started talking
he pulled out a gun
and shot me once
twice
directly in the chest
at that point do you remember if you
were still holding the phone with the
attorney i believe i was
did you have anything else in your hands
no
how tall are you
five four
do you know how tall
dr barriston is
i believe he's six four
[Music]
did you see the gun
i did
[Music]
do you remember
how he was holding the gun
[Music]
was it close to his body or pointed out
and held away from his body
just kind of like
pulled it out
pointed it
boom
boom
just like that
can you tell the jury
what you remember seeing
or hearing
when he fired the gun
wait i'm sorry
can you repeat that
sure
can you remember or can you tell the
jury what you remember seeing
or hearing
when michael barissone fired the gun
i remember
when he fired it
whatever seeing her hearing
i remember seeing my chest
um
why'd you look at your chest
it was almost unreal to me
that
i just gotten shot
so i looked at my chest quickly
see
are there really holes there like
this this can't be real
um i also then saw
michael raise his arm up
and shoot at robert who was on
the porch still just directly raised his
arm
shot at robert
and then robert disappeared
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm
okay
okay
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
come here come on
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so i need to get the person's
description okay black white necessary
his name is michael
he's white
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
are you
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
you
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box